the path of least resistance never makes
you happy it's like it do you have to
push yourself when people talk about
self-esteem I hate this term like so
many kids were taught to get a
participation trophy for something and
they thought I'm going to build their
self-esteem this way people can tell
your whole life you're a piece of crap
and your brain can go screw you I'll
show you and you become somebody people
your whole life can tell you you're
beautiful you're perfect you're the best
and you can still not believe them be
depressed about your life and think
you're nobody your life self-esteem your
self-esteem esteem for yourself is
earned by you doing something difficult
for you when you do something that's
incredibly hard and you push through it
your brain starts to have inner Pride
not fake ego Pride right so you're
saying none of that other so so that
outside of stuff doesn't really matter
your self-esteem is truly based on your
relationship with yourself yes and your
ability to grow I mean what makes people
happy progress if you get some Big Goal
you I'm sh a lot of them in your life
right there's one of two responses when
you achieve the goal yeah the horrible
one is is this all there is which a lot
of people do after fighting for a goal
this older is oh yeah but the but the
other one is let's say oh this is
amazing how long does that amazing
feeling of achieving your goal last six
years a year 6 months 6 days 6 hours
what would you say um the actual it for
me it doesn't last really long I don't
feel that kind of stuff very much yeah
well also you'd be Numb by those drugs
right but for most people somewhere
between 6 hours and probably six weeks
right so not super long no and so the
purpose of life is not just to get your
goals your goals or you're getting what
you want doesn't make you happy what
makes you happy is who you become in
pursuit of those goals so the growth the
progress even if you don't achieve it
yet but you start losing weight or you
start building muscle or you start
making your relationship better or you
start to build a business the building
the progress is what makes you feel
alive because we're all made to either
grow or die if your relationship's not
growing it's dying if your business is
not growing it's dying there's no in
between [__] that doesn't work so
and when you grow you have something to
give and what makes people fulfill bu is
growing and giving sharing it with
somebody because there's only so much
joy you can have by yourself drugs
alcohol Entertainment sex with yourself
whatever by yourself there's a limit to
what you can feel that's why whenever
something great happens most of us want
to tell someone share with somebody we
love because when you share it it
magnifies it so that's really what we're
trying to show people is how to create
that kind of progress and the problem in
New Year's is as you said a resolution
is just like what do I want and they
don't think about it in any depth they
say it and then here's the problem they
don't take it beyond that they have no
plan right or it's a very simple plan
and by February 1 by the 1st of February
95% of those things are already broken
but what they're really is is put my
years resolution in
December you know well you need a path
and so if you want to make your
relationship better your business better
your life better it starts with knowing
what you want you got say what do I want
why do I want it and what kind of person
would I have to be to have that stay and
then you got to a second step where you
got to tell yourself find and tell
yourself the truth which is is there's a
gap between where I am and where I want
to be and don't [__] yourself don't
go I'm I'm a little overweight or I'm
fat cuz I'm big boned no you're fat cuz
you have poor habits right that's how it
works yeah some people yeah I remember
this the people always like he'll grow
out of it and I'm like dude he's 34 like
my buddy's Grandma's like it's just baby
fat he'll grow out of it it's like we
all have different but it's like he
ain't [__] you know Ronnie ain't grow
out the reason you don't grow out of it
is you have to see what's causing you to
have that Gap and it's one of only a
couple things either you got fear so
you're not taking action or you might
have for example uh some limiting
beliefs like it never works I've tried
everything the good ones are gone so you
don't even begin or you might have some
emotion gets in the way or a bad habit
or maybe you're just missing the skill
like no one's ever taught you how to
make money or grow a business or have a
great relationship so you're learning on
the job and it's painful to learn on the
job so I've always said find somebody
who's extraordinary at something or many
people figure out what they're doing and
do that it's called modeling kind of
Reinventing the wheel now you can add
yourself to it yeah but modeling gives
you the pathway to power and then once
you know what you want why you want it
you're honest about the Gap you come up
with a quick plan not a perfect one and
you start taking action and then you
face your demons you slay your dragons
what needs to change like okay I'm never
going to have a relationship if I'm numb
all the time so I got to I got to change
this it's hard but I'm I'm going to do
the hard thing right and when you do the
hard thing you get momentum and then
what was hard becomes easy after a while
and that's really the secret for changes
to last it has to become your identity
let me explain we all have a way of
defining ourselves to ourselves so for
example if you see Lance Armstrong right
was the greatest biker of all time he
gets told that he has cancer not just
cancer cancer in his lungs cancer in his
brain and oh yeah in your testicles oh
by the way I ride a bike for a living
they told he's going to die but his core
belief is I always find the way so he
survived cancer most people don't he
also found a way to win no matter what
he broke the rules to do it and that
cost his brand and so forth but the same
thing that made him healthy actually got
him into trouble in the biking side but
before he used drugs he was still
unbelievable one of the best in the
world and guess what he got there
because of a belief so you have to have
a new identity his identity I find the
way made him healthy so think of it this
way if I set the thermostat in this room
at I think it'll relate to this let's
say 68° okay all right and that's a
metaphor for your comfort zone your
identity this is you know that's 68
degrees is how much not much money I
want but what you know what I'm used to
68 degrees is what I'm used to in a
relationship it's not the it's not what
I want but you know it's okay you know
it's pretty good it's what I know you
know so think of that as comfort zone
now if the temperature drops to 65 64 62
59 all of a sudden the brain the
computer goes hey you're a 68 degree or
what you doing at 59 and I'm sure you've
experienced it like this is [__] and
like boom suddenly the heaters kick on
and you got drive and you go deal with
it you go lose lose the weight or you
get off the drugs you do whatever it is
but here's the part that most people
understand let's say you get back to
where you were and now you get new
momentum and you're doing better you go
to 69 70 80 89 9 99 degrees and all a
sudden the brain goes what the hell you
doing up here you're a 68 deger you're
not a 99 deger and the first thing that
happens is the heaters stop and you stop
growing and then if that's not enough
the air conditioners kick on and you
start to sabotage yourself till you get
back to where you believe you are so
cigarettes if you you used to smoke
right so if I came to you today and I
offer you a cigarette what would you say
no sir nobody or nobody no sir no no sir
no sir nobody okay you know so why
because I don't want it yeah why because
I don't doesn't make me happy anymore
yeah most people have you wouldn't say
what brand is it you go no and the
reason why is you're no longer a smoker
it's not your identity ah if you thought
you're a smoker you might go what brand
is it well maybe I'll have one you know
whatever it is right it's like when
people tell me you know I'm on day four
of not drinking or not smoking I'm go
why you counting so you can tell people
how many days you last this time before
you go back again it's like when you
change your identity I'm not one of
those you're not going to do it anymore
so you are in the midst of transforming
your identity you're in the middle of it
right now and you're doing a beautiful
job I'm not again blowing smoke I'm not
a bullshitter man no but I hope you take
it in because you need to own that on
your own your own instincts have led you
to a place of real progress you're not
there yet not where you want to be and
by when you get wherever there is it
won't be enough you'll want to do more
cuz we're all supposed to keep growing
that's what makes us
happy